[Music]  this story explained things very clearly  and it takes it step by step knee  doesn't make you feel rushed and I feel  that I generally enjoy going to mass  classes a lot more it's the best result  anyone can tell but I've do recommend it  to a few of my friends that go from  different schools that I get with and I  say if you're having problems go look  this up my teacher is great he's very  helpful it will really help you didn't  believe it from the first day I saw a  mister were in my class it's absolutely  amazing you know if you want to come  into the classroom and every day you  learn new things and you enjoy it more  than other things the kind of